Почему ты не радуешься у тебя такое
событие происходит Ты вообще кто такой
мне кого-то ещё рекомендовать и
он за 5 секунд вот этого пролис тиктока
испытываю смерть счастье любовь свадьбу
драку там же вот так реально специально
деградируют я молился это был мой намаз
практически Сначала ты потом тебе
Счастье нас убивает
[музыка]
друзья Добрый день Сегодня мы начинаем
наш очередной г подкаст я уже даже
соскучился по такому формату
неформального общения и я наконец
выпустил свою книгу она так и называется
технология счастливой жизни миссия
выполнима Поздравляю спасибо большое мы
сделали презентацию книги пока она
держится в бестселлера Надеюсь также и
будет держать сегодня на этот гем
подкаст я собрал людей которые считаю
очень интересные люди для всех вас для
меня в том числе
Напомнить формат нашего МБО подкаста мы
не собираем здесь экспертов это не
экспертное сообщество Мы сюда собираем
просто интересных людей и это знаете как
такие кухонные Посиделки где хочется
поговорить за жизнь но в отличие от
просто подкастов мы обсуждаем по
конкретным темам у нас не обо всём А у
нас по конкретным темам тематикам чтобы
иначе говорить Можно бесконечно обо всём
и чтобы это не превратилось в такого
пусто порожню болтовню когда есть тема
всё всё-таки она более структурирована и
люди получают большую пользу Итак
сегодня с нами в гостях Давайте по
традиции Обычно я не представляю гости
мы даём такую возможность гостям самим
представить себя как вы себя видите
Давайте слева направо представим
Дулат Многие знают Как зак А из группы
на One сотер автор текстов рэпер и тд и
тп Меня зовут
Арман Я являюсь основателем онлайн
университета
поток Ну меня зовут маргулан Я ведущий
этого Подкасты Меня зовут осель
Садвакасова я даже не знаю как себя
правильно с позиционировать сейчас до
этого сидели говорили что и в
шоу-бизнесе была и в кинобизнес была и в
блогерское сфере Поэтому просто наверное
счастливая
женщина классно всё сложно теперь после
этого стало меня зовут
Оскар Мне 27 лет я актёр стремлюсь быть
артистом стремлюсь выйти за рамки актёр
Сва тема сегодняшней нашей встречи и
нашего подкаста - Это счастье Кто как
понимает как его достичь из чего Она
состоит и так далее коротко можно
назвать ключи к счастью Итак первый
вопрос о котором я хотел поговорить Ну
конечно прежде всего Ну хочу подчеркнуть
что мы в той или иной мере каждый
человек в принципе профессионал в плане
того что такое счастье Ну это не
какая-то специальная учебная дисциплина
которую надо пройти университет потом
только он становится экспертом нет
Каждый из нас внутри мы осознаём это
какое-то врождённое ощущение и чувство
что есть такое состояние как счастье Да
но это нам даже особо это не учили но
вот в каждом из нас сидит такой Аля
идеал как мы должны себя чувствовать по
сути да И вот я хотел бы сегодня сначала
провести такую диагностику наших гостей
как вы себя ощущаете кто себя считает
счастливым Или давайте так возьмём А
ваше представление о счастье возьмём за
десятку и на На каком уровне вы себя
сейчас чувствуете по отношению к с тем
представлением о счастье которое вы
имеете М Можно я первая такая да тем
более ты сказал что ты счастливая
женщина Ну теперь Отвечай за свои слова
А вот по моим наблюдениям лично за самой
собой я поняла что вообще единой вот
этой формулы счастья её Конечно нет и в
разные периоды жизни Для меня счастье -
это вообще разные вещи и даже за весь
день я могу испытывать счастье
совершенно с разных сторон И я
определилась что самое важное конечно
это чтобы были закрыты определённые
базовые потребности это здоровье чтобы
было крепким это какая-то финансовая
наверное независимость чтобы было что
поесть где поспать и тогда уже на эту
основу оно ложится Мне кажется всё что
угодно например сегодня я была счастлива
от того что а утром проснулась И у меня
вот просто было ощущение того что а
что-то хорошее вот сегодня будет
происходить и вот в таком воодушевленно
состоянии я проснулась Бывает так что в
парке гуляю белочку увижу и вот у меня
вот прямо ощущение такого счастья маму
встречаю Вот и и что интересно оно не в
постоянном таком состоянии ты находишься
оно меняется
у это знаете я ла на бале по года и там
действительно такой наступает момент что
тебе каждый день очень хорошо и ты
понимаешь что ты от этого тоже немного
устаёшь и тебе хочется уже каких-то
эмоций тебе хочется какой-то жизни Вот я
вернулась в Казахстан я сейчас испытываю
жизнь в день по нескольку раз И вот
Очень классно когда ты его я поняла что
самое важное вот когда тебе очень хорошо
его запомнить
е запомнить и когда тебе очень плохо или
что-то происходит чтобы в это сильно не
скатиться по вспоминать Вот эти все
Моменты Ну то есть мне это очень
помогает Ну вот На сколько ты оцениваешь
своё состояние Ну вот сегодня мне
кажется на все 10 на все
10 из десяточку выбила так Аль Так кто
ещё оценит своё состояние
9 8.9 8.9 ниф себе
чуть-чуть чуть-чуть не доходит до девяти
если бы э прям хорошенько выспался
наверное было бы девять угу вот а хорошо
представим что ты хорошо выспался и что
чего не хватает для того чтобы выбить
десятку А наверное не
хватает как-то момента что ли какого-то
момента осознания э себя вот у меня
просто в последнее время вот эти
последние несколько месяцев с самим
собой идёт диалог такой
большой насчёт Правды своей Ну Кукушка
не съехала но не не нормально наоборот
хорошо то есть Она постепенно
поднимается вот эта вот шкала счастья на
самом деле поскольку начал осознавать то
что счастье заключается в том что ну моё
счастье заключается в том
что чувствовать свободу а чувствую
свободу я когда беру ответственность за
свою правду но это не всегда получается
то есть Да иногда я не могу брать
ответственность за свою правду То есть
это мне немного мешает в жизнь в
принципе ограничиваю где-то где-то
подавляет то есть не полностью раскрываю
не проявляются вот а как только я с этим
справлюсь Я думаю вот будет десятка
Классно классно так Арман м хронически
ощущаю себя где-то на восемь из 10
А даже девять А в моменте сейчас где-то
6 тире се потому что есть определённые
там моменты я вот вернулся там с отпуска
сейчас в работу возвращаюсь У меня
сейчас идёт запуск там моего обучения и
у меня много задач рабочих и они
немножко друг на друга сейчас наложили и
из-за этого я всё время
ощущаю Вот я мало сейчас присутствую в
настоящем я То есть постоянно думаю о
следующих событиях в течение дня О
действиях Мне нужно сделать о решениях
которые мне нужно принять и они как бы
накапливаются параллельно в голове и
энергия немножко сливается туда и
появляется такая фоновая немножко
тревожность что-то Типа такого но это
очень такое решаемо Я Слава Богу
благодарен за всё что у меня в жизни
происходит это хорошие хлопоты но просто
как оцениваю вот так сейчас себ Да
кстати очень хорошо подметил Да это я
всегда тоже говорю что счастье убивает
это сожаление прошлом и беспокойство о
будущем когда ты не находишься в моменте
Здесь и сейчас это прямо действительно
работает меня Я думаю восем из десяти
восем и сейчас подумал о том что счастье
оно чувствуется почему-то в прошедшем
времени когда я я для себя осознал что я
счастлив где-то всегда в
прошлом я был тогда счастлив этот момент
сст понял что нужно вот Правильные мысли
се я думаю что фиксировать Да вот если
всё хорошо зафиксировать это меня это
помогает мне это помогает в этом дневник
личный Я прямо много пишу и вот это
фиксирует и я пишу я такой О я счастлив
и это мне не даёт забыть о том что в
целом всё хорошо Все здоровы Все живы а
ощущение счастья наверное да в
спокойствии когда ты не думаешь наперёд
далеко а это это что и не назад А когда
ты вот фу всё хорошо вот в такие моменты
думаю я а как ты дневник ведёшь ты в
моменте ведёшь или ты там в конце дня
допустим с утра как ты это делаешь
сейчас вот да снова я начал три страницы
в день с утра Вот я сегодня не писал Но
с утра это очень полезная практика для
фиксации во-первых для во-вторых для
это то что вот ты проснулся и из
подсознания всё выписывает можешь за
собой Со стороны пронаблюдать это твой
как бы луч друг который с тобой Ты
можешь по нему как равняться как
камертон с дневник Поэтому с утра с утра
я думаю это самое Там точно знаете сразу
такой лайфхак скажу очень интересный
Когда пишете такой дневник лучше всего
писать не как дневник а фиксации А как
Письмо к себе
будущему и вот тогда интересно
перечитать когда ты пишешь письмо себе
будущему и ты читаешь через какое-то
время обязательно Возьмите
се время например читать Через месяц
например то что написал сегодня читать
Через месяц или через 3 месяца или через
год но для себя выберите временной
промежуток И когда вы пишете письмо себе
будущему вы автоматически анализируется
Всё своё прошлое А и Делайте как бы
выводы и и советуйте себе будущему
Смотри вот так не делай Вот это это а
вот это нужно делать Вот так вот так и
когда ты с будущего начинаешь это читать
ты понимаешь Большую разницу между тем
Ты что ты сейчас чувствуешь и что
чувствовал тот человек исходя из того
опыта и ты чувствуешь как ты вырос это
вот эта разница в росте ты чувствуешь
это такой чёткий показатель твоего
прогресса ты думаешь блин этот человек 3
месяца назад мне вот это рекомендовал
Сейчас бы это не делал потому что это ну
это не работает Блин какой он был глупый
там 3 месяца назад или наоборот блин
оказывается тогда Я ближе был к истине
чем сейчас и потому что когда вы пишете
просто рефлексию о том что вот Произошло
это то читать немного Скучновато А когда
вы читаете представьте себе Вот есть
хорошая
книжка Сенека к луцилию Да вот они
раньше древние греки письмами там
общались и понятно книга Письма к
луцилию и вот ты Письма к себе будущему
Назови себя
как-то письма будущему там я и или там
имя своё поставь и так далее сделай
переписку между собой настоящим и собой
прошлым Угу У меня так
э терапия проходит я так У меня тоже я
вёл дневник и она родилась такая терапия
в виде диалога я всегда пишу Сначала это
просто что-то внутри меня тревожило
внутри был сильный дискомфорт и Я не
понимал Почему и просто вот так начал
писать привет привет через диалог как
дела Нормально Что гонишь Расскажи что
как себя чувствуешь Ну так так Окей А
почему что ты чувствуешь Что тебя
тревожит и начал из себя вот в диалоге
вот так из себя вытаскивать что мне
комфортно что
некомфортно Но я это назвал разговор
сердца с мозгом как будто душа с мозгом
Да тоже пробовал работа родитель и
ребёнок вот у меня там позиция одного
мудрый человек появляется который
спокойно даёт советы Ну спокойно у тебя
всё будет и ребёнок который капризничает
который говорит стоп это не нравится
почему то то то то Ну лучше такой диалог
вести в разных состояниях потому что
смотри когда ты в проблеме например ты
эмоционально
вовлечённость и переживать он либо
переживает либо думает а соответственно
Проблема в том что когда ты в проблеме
ты не можешь принять рациональное
решение потому что эмоции тебя
захватывают и ты эмоционально реагируешь
на всё А вот именно на этом построена
технология моя когда я делаю алгоритм
решения проблем до того как проблемы
случаются то есть То есть например со
мной случился какой-нибудь факап
проблема Я сразу делаю алгоритм Я вообще
всё алгоритми зру по возможности
алгоритм и этот алгоритм когда наступает
какая-то ситуация эмоциональная я сразу
же осознаю что в этой ситуации Я не могу
принять рациональное решение поэтому я
открываю алгоритм читаю и просто
действую по алгоритму потому что
алгоритм был написан Когда я был в
спокойном состоянии когда меня эмоции не
трогали когда я всё проанализировал
кажды
так Дале и так далее И это это как
бы получается такая программа которая
меня спасает из вот этих эмоциональных
состояний Поэтому если общаешься вот
мозг с сердцем тогда когда ты на эмоциях
ты пишешь от имени сердца а мозг должен
отвечать когда ты в спокойном состоянии
когда действительно работает мозг А то
получается самообман вроде мозг с
сердцем общается на самом деле сердце с
сердцем общается Да а вообще в
психологии рекомендуют вопрос задавать
правой рукой а отвечать левой это ещё
тогда вот так правильный будет ответ Это
ещё Поче как ребёнка я пробовал эту
практику ты вопрос задаёшь правой рукой
как взрослый красивой а отвечаешь левой
рукой у тебя почер Но в этот момент Зато
ты замедляется вот как вы говорите
эмоции они начинаются тиха и и это на
самом деле ещё э убирает все лишние шумы
потому что это новые нейроны
[музыка]
но в целом
смотрите что я
заметил Ну а вы насколько себя ощущаете
я вообще я так сказал я себя ощущаю
наверное постоянно Ну в районе
десятки причём в любое время Это не
вопрос такой смотрите Здесь очень важно
понимать счастье - это не радость
радость это функци
ког вып гормонов ты радуешься Да а
счастье - это ощущение баланса Угу
гармонии и принятия То есть три основных
характеристики первое баланс Что такое
баланс мы все любим испытывать А чтобы
было счастье у нас должно быть ощущение
позитивного баланса Что такое позитивный
баланс Ты когда ты чётко понимаешь что в
этой жизни есть го горести беды
несчастья факапы неудачи ошибки и так
далее ты это понимаешь
и принимаешь дальше но ты понимаешь что
существуют Победы радости и так далее и
так далее так вот побед радости там
хороших событий должно быть
60% а 40 всех этих негативов и тогда
получается так да ты понимаешь что есть
Тёмная сторона но позитивного больше в
результате этого ощущения Ты всегда
понимаешь такую ве что как индусы
говорят ВС всегда заканчивается хорошо
ели Плохо значит это ещ не
конец и вот это чувство позитивного
баланса тебе даёт вот эту веру и надежду
Даже тогда когда тебе плохо это не
значит что счастливый человек это он
всегда на позитиве радостный Нет ты
можешь грустить ты можешь горевать и так
далее но ты парадоксально при этом ты
можешь оставаться
счастливым ещё важный момент чувство
гармонии Что такое гармония гармония -
это наличие всех компонентов необходимых
для счастья в идеально пропорции Угу угу
именно пропорция важна то есть во-первых
здесь две вещи должно быть наличие всех
компонентов второе они должны находиться
в идеальной пропорции Угу Как соус И
третье - это это принятие потому что мы
думаем что для того чтобы быть
счастливым у нас с нами должны
происходить только хорошие вещи на самом
деле до тех пор пока ты не примешь мир с
таким какой он есть со всеми бео
безобразия несправедливостью злом и так
далее то у тебя счастье не произойдёт
потому что всё время тебе что-то будет
мешать А мешать будет то что ты не
принимаешь ты говоришь этого не должно
быть жизни а это как раз тебя будет
настигает это принятие очень важно И вот
то что мы сегодня обговорили мне
интересно я слушаю и вот это интересно
вот я в книге об этом тоже писал что
смотрите есть пять компонентов счастья
которые необходимы чтобы было счастье
Первое - это здоровье второе это
безопасность Кстати это то же самое как
счастье Мы не можем это прощупать
увидеть почувствовать Вот ты сказал
насчёт счастья что в прошлом на самом
деле не так сейчастье невозможно
почувствовать но древние греки сказали
что счастье можно доказать через приём
Вио негатива Вио негатива - Это от
обратного что счастье ты чувствуешь
тогда когда его у тебя нет М точно
потому что когда оно у тебя есть ты его
не чувствуешь это как воздух ты не
и вот Счастье когда я начал задумываться
Она состоит из таких же компонентов как
оно есть само то есть здоровье Когда оно
есть мы думаем Ну по умолчанию вот
нормальное состояние понимаете Здоровье
нормальное состояние мы когда нездоровы
только мы начинаем понимать что блин Что
такое
здоровь безопасность мы его не замечаем
это как само собой разумеющееся но стоит
нам попасть в опасность мы понимаем что
такое безопасность точно дальше Свобода
смотрите Свобода у нас как Как воздух мы
его воспринимаем как данность но стоит
нам оказаться в не свободе мы остро
чувствуем Что мы не свободны Угу дальше
это
а любимые люди вокруг туда входят не
только партнёры там А туда входят родные
близкие друзья учителя там коллеги
хорошие и так далее вот любимые люди
когда есть мы воспринимаем тоже на
автопилоте Мы даже можем нагрубить
нахамить их мы их не замечаем и так
далее но когда их нету мы сразу
чувствуем пустоту Угу у и пятый фактор -
это любимое дело когда нету любимого
дела Ты чувствуешь бессмысленность своей
жизни и вот вот этих пять факторов
Интересно что наличие всех факторов не
гарантирует счастье но отсутствие любого
из них гарантирует
несчастье класс и вот вы сегодня то что
проговорили
вот и ты говорил Ну все по очереди Вы по
сути говорили Финан финансовая это нужна
безопасность Смотрите Они свою очередь
делится безопасность делится на
физическую безопасность финансовую
безопасность юридическую безопасность
Угу а то же самое как Свобода делится на
физическую свободу экономическую свободу
юридическую свободу и ментальную свободу
вот приведу Пример например что такое
юридическая свобода Да вы хотите поехать
в США у вас нету визы у вас нет
юридической Свободы Угу Или вы хотите
вводить свой Ferrari А у вас нету прав у
вас нету юридических свобод классно Или
например вы хотите водить Ferrari у вас
права есть но денег нет у вас нету
экономической
Свободы то есть денег нет а физическая
Свобода Понятно Если вы в тюрьме закрыты
Там и так далее Но самое интересное у
всех нас самое большое узкое Горошко
которое ограничивает рост всех нас это
наша ментальная
несвобода мы сами себе на создавали кучу
ментальных тюрм и не можем выйти за них
не ляет что скажут что подумает А вдруг
то а вдруг с ты познакомился с крутым
человеком Он дал тебе телефон и ты
боишься ему позвонить думаешь Да он
занят наверное Да ему наверное не до
меня и так далее ты сам себе выстроил
ограничение психическом мире живёт и ты
живёшь в своей ментальной тюрьме и не
можешь
перешагнуть таким
образом видите счастье она имеет вот эти
компоненты из которых состоит и эти
компоненты нужно иметь это получается
здоровье пре здоровье потом безопасность
безопасность потом Свобода Свобода потом
любимые люди любимые люди и
лю Как у тебя со всеми пунктами Давай
разберём что у тебя там
происходит на самом деле каждая каждый
вот этот компонент крайне важен это как
раз те компоненты которые необходимы но
они необходимы в идеальной пропорции
чтобы была гармония Потому что если
ударите столько в свою безопасность то
вы вас назовут параноиком Угу как знаете
который везде слежка везде это там Если
вы ударите столько в зарабатывание денег
там экономическую безопасность то вас
будет считать что вы на деньгах
зациклены и у вас действительно счастья
не будет точно Вот именно для счастья
вот нужно наличие всех этих компонентов
и гармония между ними то есть пропорции
они ещё иногда компенсируют друг друга
Да если не хватает там любви допустим
любимых людей ты компенсирует это в деле
ты как-то пытаешься всё рано Они
компенсируют до определённой степени
дисбаланс получается Они до определённой
степени только компенсируют Но полностью
компенсировать не могут точно Ну это
знаете как вот мне нравится определение
денег Деньги не приносят счастье но они
помогают пережить
несчастье видите она как бы компенсирует
но счастье они не приносят но несчастье
они компенсируют где-то что-то у тебя
раз обезболивающее на самом деле типа ты
не убираешь саму причину боли ты Да ты
просто следствие Ты только со следствием
берёшь и его как бы заглушается и всё на
самом деле Угу Да И вот смотрите Здесь э
а самое Интересно что по ощущению Ну то
что я для себя определил что счастье оно
на самом деле нами не управляется Угу мы
не можем быть счастливыми по
заказу а Ну мне кажется М это можно
развить то есть мне кажется на самом
деле то что вот такие эфемерные вещи
тонкие они на самом деле тоже как Скил
идут то есть счастье удача я не знаю
такие вещи которыми мы как бы не можем
управлять Но на самом деле на уровне
энергии так скажем на уровне вибрации мы
можем обратку дать То есть мне лично
помогает например в какие-то моменты
когда я просто грустный или когда мне э
тяжело допустим я начинаю просто
улыбаться Угу специально улыбаться это в
Акт и после чего у
меня постепенно вот это вот
перестраивается это влияет уже на мои
гормоны гормоны влияют на мой вайб и
вайп уже потихоньку меняется и потом
изнутри уже идёт что-то другое и обратно
возвращается то есть типа это всегда так
идёт да да Когда актёру надо либо
заплакать одна из техник Ну то есть если
не может войти в роль а либо заплакать
либо засмеяться нужно специально это
делать и через какое-то время через
несколько минут человек начинает реально
уже испытывать эти эмоции либо плакать
либо смеяться вот тоже Ну это такой вот
да накрученный Ну это такая Да на самом
деле это временная штука Но это хорошо
помогает момент да с чем-то справиться
что-то переварить вот тоже добавлю Я был
на обучении там у Тони робинсона и он
рассказывал Прямо именно делился
научными фактами о том что допустим есть
поза Супергероя Вот такая ты когда Вот
стоишь минут 10 в ней то у тебя на 25%
Кортизол падает и на сколько-то там
увеличивается этот тестостерон я не
Эксперт в этой теме но у меня есть
где-то скриншот Я вам отправлю можно
вотт сюда вставить потом на монтаже Ну
вот это про то что ну условно на уровне
химии внутри Да это всё можно
действительно поднять и он ещё
рекомендовал ему 62 года Тони Робинсон
он такой очень заряженный дядька ему У
не У него там супер состояние и в
деньгах и во всё
он прыгает в день сся раз и я с тех пор
начал с утра прыгать и вот ты прыгаешь я
ещё руки Поднимаю в этот момент и
реально вот да просто ты прыгаешь и тебе
постепенно Ты замечаешь как Становится
лучше Ну тупо вот на уровне тела потом
ты останавливаешься и твоя как бы твоё
состояние оно реально меняется в момент
я вот хотел ещ тоже добавить такой
момент что я тоже согласен что счастье -
это выбор это не про то что типа ты либо
получаешь либо вот ждёшь это ты
выбираешь как я это понял В последнее
время для себя вот у меня есть какая-то
проблема И если я чувствую слив энергии
значит я смотрю не с того ракурса я
понимаю что условно есть люди в мире для
которых эта проблема не была бы
проблемой условно там для президента или
там для кого-то там крутого Да У кого
большой калибр проблема она была бы
просто там будний день я просто стараюсь
искать Тот ракурс при котором Когда Я о
нём думаю у меня идт знаешь да и меньше
и прилив энергии и я просто вот эти
моменты себе выписываю как алгоритм
Теперь как мне мыслить и потом я туда
направляю свой фокус и перестаю
думать деструктивно то есть так как я
сливаю энергию потому что я понимаю если
я солью энергию у меня не будет сил
действовать если я не буду действовать
Ничего не поменяется поэтому это
нелогично не выгодно быть в этой позиции
Я ищу выгодный ракурс для себя Поэтому я
считаю что счастье - это такая духовная
мышца которую можно прокачивать Да и Ну
вот это выбор блин по идее здесь хочется
добавить мне как-то мама сказала очень
интересную вещь то что Единственное чем
мы действительно владеем это наше
внимание то есть мы не владеем на самом
деле то есть мы не владельцы своего тела
времени там ээ всяких там ресурсов
которые вот физически материальные Но
единственное что мы чем мы можем
осознанно владеть это нашим вниманием на
самом деле то есть э мы можем им
управлять мы можем его направлять мы
можем э его просто отпустить но прикол в
том что когда э внимание как-то хаотично
ты Ты просто сыпешь тебя в принципе нет
ты нигде ты на автомате Ты просто где-то
там короче и Ну на самом деле мы это и
есть наше внимание то есть сгусток того
что наше внимание
Ээ нам привело короче грубо говоря Вот и
по сути это очень интересно потому что
мне как-то вот недавно где-то недели две
назад делали массаж Он был очень
болезненный очень болючий массаж и я
лежал кричал прямо то есть мне прямо
буквально плакать хотелось Я лежал
кричал и масс говорит типа успокойся это
Это не ты болеешь у тебя просто твоё
тело болит короче угу Она говорит это
просто твоё тело болит короче это не ты
и я такой а ни хрена себе и и потом
отпустила
прикиньте Просто я короче переключил
внимание такое осознал что так Это же
просто моё тело оно может Ну типа я могу
просто не чувствовать и всё Ну я хотела
бы вот добавить вот это а м позиция То
что приводить себя там специально в это
состояние контролировать Да следить за
вниманием это очень круто но Лично мне
это не помогало долгий период времени
потому что
у меня всегда была тревожность я сама по
себе очень позитивный человек и я думаю
только вот на этом позитиве Конечно я
дошла до определённой точки но уже потом
я начала понимать что она не помогает Я
вот пытаюсь в течение дня поднимать себе
настроение делать себе что-то хорошая но
всё равно Вот это да меня беспокоила
очень сильно моя тревожность очень
сильно беспокоила и я не знала что с ней
делать и я вот реально попробовала всё
что могла пока всё-таки не поняла что
нужно углубиться вну
и вот когда я начала проделывать вот эту
глубинную работу внутри себя вот о ЧМ вы
говорите вот тогда я вышла Вот в это
состояние постоянного счастья это когда
действительно всё что угодно может
происходить Но вот это я прямо начала я
помню первый раз у меня был очень
сильный Я помню стресс А я такая вся в
дзене У меня всё так хорошо Я наконец
такая счастье испытываю тревога ушла и
произошел какой-то стресс я плачу что-то
там проходит и я чувствую внутри меня то
чего раньше не было состояние счастья
Вот какая-то моя часть она всё равно
счастлива я вот этот момент я помню аж
замерла и подумала Господи Благодарю и я
Ду я вот так потом ходила в течение
нескольких месяцев и прямо наблюдала не
уйдёт Она никуда она никуда не денется и
потом я начала понимать что А вот он
смысл жизни он видимо в этом и
заключается Я испытываю все эмоции Я
испытываю все свои там я не знаю всё что
могу а а я женщина естественно я в день
это миллион раз испытываю у меня вот
такие качели Но вот это состояние
перманентного счастья Ощутив баланса в
жизни оно оно оказывается не уходит и
всё и я такая думаю вот это вот вот это
стоит того чтобы погрузиться внутрь себя
настолько глубоко болезненно Да но
интересно чтобы вот начать ощущать и
тогда По моим ощущениям даже ничего
искать во вне не нужно потом ну смыс
Да это уже тво состояние и вот это вот
мне очень понравилась фраза в
принятии любых любого себя без
идеализации какой-то Вот это наверное
самое такое самое счастье
реально
Да мы как ты себя вытаскиваешь из Вот
это очень хорошая тема насчёт внимания
что у меня недавно ходили вот с другом
меня друг с Москвы приехал ему показы Ну
в алмаату и мы ходили на Бао и вот там у
меня было ощущение что расцветает то
куда я смотрю вот просто Мысль о том что
я смотрю сюда там иванча И фиолетовые
горы и у меня было ощущение что куда я
посмотрю то расцветает И я такой О это
здравая мысль это очень здоровая мысль
расцветает то куда ты Направляешь своё
Внимание это напрямую
связано дыхание Вот вот что я подумал
что один очень умный человек мне сказал
что э четыре стихии Ну пять по сути есть
есть Земля Вода Огонь
ээ воздух и эфир эфир Я не знаю что это
э ну какое-то сознание якобы и вот мы
состоим из четырёх вот этих компонентов
Да из земли я как бы состою из из Да
материи твёрдой из земли вода - Это
кровь во мне идёт огонь - Это моя душа
это мой огонь а единственное из всех
четырёх стихий чем я могу управлять -
Это только дыхание ничем другим я не
могу управлять землёй своей я не могу
управлять кровью я не могу огнём тоже А
вот еди это воздух только дыханием я
могу фокусироваться на себе это
единственная стихия которой я могу
управлять - это дыхание дышать
замедляться глубже дышать вот в такие
моменты вот образ счастья приходит и
второе - это у меня пропало ощущение
конкуренции Вот как раз таки в мыслях о
счастьи потому что в какой-то момент мне
пришло то что какая вообще можно быть
конкуренция Если ты не счастлив как О
чём Ну то есть за что вы боретесь если
человек который там допустим достиг
больше чем ты и он не счастлив то Кто
победитель непонятно А где вот этот
критерий Я думаю критерий единственный
есть либо ты счастлив либо ты не
счастлив ты можешь быть супер крутым
артистом бизнесменом кем угодно но если
ты не счастлив то ты получается
проигрываешь тому кто Просто ходит
гуляет живёт обыч но счастлив вот эта
вот Вот Эта мысль ощущение конкуренции У
меня просто оно испарилось то что мои
роли я сыграю не мои роли сыграют те кто
должен сыграть и как-то всё так Получи
Свобода это кайф это Свобода это свобода
реально книг вот эту мысль читал что
есть счастливы А успешные но не
счастливые но нет как не счастливых А я
видел много успешных людей но не все из
них были счастливы но я не видел ни
одного счастливого человека который
считал бы себя не успешным это 100% так
на самом деле основной измеритель
успешности в этом мире в этой жизни это
только насколько ты счастлив вот здесь
Вы хорошие темы затронули но смотрите
Давайте по порядку начнём Арман ты
говорил про энергию вот у меня есть в
этой же книге как раз блок про
управление энергией
а Power Management У меня даже отдельный
курс по этому поводу есть Дело в том что
смотрите этот мир состоит из двух видов
энергии Светлая энергия тёмная энергия
при этом э в этом мире есть асимметрия
добра и зла Ну Добро - Это как Светлая
энергия зло как тёмная энергия
соотношение примерно Если Вы посмотрите
на Звёздное небо ночью то сколько там
темноты столько в мире
э тёмной энергии сколько там Света
столько в мире там светлой энергии то
есть светлой энергии в разы меньше чем
тёмной Угу Но есть одна хорошая новость
она сильнее Да одна хорошая новость
Темнота никогда не может победить свет
а свет всегда побеждает темноту Вот его
мало но он Темнота вот невозможно
представить при котором Темнота
побеждает свет свет всегда раскрывает
темноту всегда побеждает отсу Света
тепер тепер дальше теперь дальше идём
все наши хорошие качества они по
подпитывают за счёт светлой энергии
благородство терпимость сопереживание
сочувствие щедрость доброта дисциплина Л
всё подпитывается за счёт светлой
энергии Представьте вы идёте с работы
уставший голодный холодный А и у вас
руки дрожат от голода разве Можете вы
быть благородным щедрым сочувствующий и
так далее вам легче в это время
накричать наорать сломать что-то разбить
что-то нахамить нагрубить и так далее То
есть на вот эти вещи у вас энергии
хватает получается тёмной энергии у вас
хватает в это время изза того что свет
энергии нет у вас светлых качеств нету
благородство вы не можете проявить Там и
так далее В результате получается так мы
как сосуд Когда у нас нету светлой
энергии мы автоматически заполняем
тёмной энергией и как это в жизни
работает вот предположим а для того
чтобы сделать добро Вам всегда нада
энергия для того чтобы сделать зло
практически энергия не нужна тёмная
энергия Она присутствует всегда Угу И
вот человек к вам приходит и говорит Вот
например Арман там знаешь вот есть такой
хороший человек возьми его на работу там
тос то а ты сидишь автоматически это
Любой человек сидишь и думаешь Ты вообще
кто такой мне кого-то ещё рекомендовать
Угу А представь теперь другая ситуация
пришёл человек и говорит Ты знаешь Арман
там главный бухгалтер твой по-моему
там хитрить потому что он новый джип
купил там то-сё и он ушёл и ты такой
думаешь блин давно я Тото что-то не то
блин видать бухгалтер подворот тот
человек который ты даже не
подвергает сделать добро тот человек
который хотел сделать кому-то добро
рекомендовать он должен пройти через
фильтр репутации А тот который хотел
сделать [__] Он легко раз и мы
автоматически поверили его словам и
начали думать даже СМИ
элемента Вот вот асимметрия добра и зла
заметьте все СМИ пестрят авариями
изнасилованием убийствами и так далее
Потому что не все люди имеют светлую
энергию чтобы что-то позитивно читать но
дурной энергия у человека всегда в
избытке и Они читают все эти новости и
бо просмотров больше обсуждения это
порождает
но мотивацию публиковать Это то что
касается энергии теперь очень важный
момент по вниманию вообще что такое
Внимание Внимание - это
особый механизм концентрации времени и
энергии это механизм концентрации
времени и энергии куда вы направляете
внимание туда направляется ваше время и
энергия это как краник горячей холодной
воды а время и энергия соединяются и
этот краник называется внимание Вот куда
вы направляет внимание то всё расцветает
вы как поливаете я это ещё называю
эликсиром жизни так вот интересный
момент А дело в том что я сам верю в
мультиварик у Почему Потому что вот
смотрите существует бесконечность да А
мы же не можем отрицать что она
существует Но бесконечность когда мы
говорим мы думаем про Вселенную там
Космос А ещё вовнутрь
атомы Может быть эти атомы чьи-то
планеты мы не знаем же там если копать
бесконечность хоть вовнутрь хоть вовне
соответственно если мы говорим этот мир
бесконечен то почему мы утверждаем что
мы
Уникальны значит где-то Есть такой же
стол такой же подкаст только на столе
нет Айпада есть ещё вариант такой же
стол такой же подкаст только у Армана
белая рубашка есть ещё такой же этот на
Сель другое платье и это бесконечное
количество вариантов даже в исламе
говорится Аллах создатель миров нигде не
говорится в исламе про в единственном
числе всегда Аллах создатель миров
вообще в исламе говорят 80.000 миров
существует Там и так далее ну факт то
что Ислам признаёт что есть бесконечно
ну огромна количество миров так вот
смотрите у оптимиста один мир одна
реальность у пессимиста Другая
реальность у верующего одна реальность у
не верш Другая реальность так вот мы
идём по этой жизни Вот на улице и мы
видим разные вещи оптимист видит
улыбающегося таксиста хорошую погоду
солнце собачку птички щебечи вроде мир
один но тоже врем а пессимист видит
совсем другое запрещающие знаки там
плачущего ребёнка мать которую бьёт там
ещё что-то и вот он видит совсем другое
и вот что происходит вот внимание наше
внимание оно как она как собачка Когда у
нас нету цели мы не знаем что хотим наша
собачка бегает как дворняжка вокруг там
по писяет там по гавкает там птичку
погоняет и так далее на
360° и мы не знаем когда мы не знаем
чего хотим А когда мы знаем что хотим У
нас есть цель то она как охот собака вот
так ищет фазана ищет и соответственно
что происходит Ты как охотник если
собака у тебя ищет фазана в этой стоне
Ты же не пойдёшь в ту сторону ты всегда
следуешь за своим вниманием так вот
Внимание - это то что выбирает ту
реальность в которой ты
окажешься если ты позитивно смотришь на
мир то внимание выбирает только
позитивные вещи и соответственно с тобой
случается реальность где много
позитивных вещей для тебя поэтому тебе
везёт у меня вообще вот в
детстве я был очень
верил вообще всему всему что показывают
по телику там фильмы мультфильмы и так
далее То есть до такой степени что когда
в первый раз увидел людей и там была
девушка которая через стены короче
пробегает и я сосредоточился и
разогнался и короче об стену шлёпнулся и
у меня до сих пор здесь шрам есть но
вообще в свом мире и у меня был фокус
всегда вот как только я встретился с
рэпом у меня весь фокус был на рэпе То
есть у нас тогда ещё не было в
Казахстане типа
популярно популярен вообще этот жанр не
было казахского рэпа там максимум были
всякие российские аналоги и так далее
жил в ауле где вообще об этом никто
ничего не знает мне дядя приносит с
города какие-то кассеты Ино вот
получается я начал сосредотачиваться на
вот этой идее стать рэпером когда я
вырасту типа вот я вырасту я стану
рэпером и каждый день прям буквально
визуализировать видел себя в этом всём
ночью спал и перед сном обязательно
короче запрашивал Бога типа я я я хочу
стать рэпером Дай мне возможность стать
рэпером типа и так далее
потом Проходит время уже прошло где-то
вот почти 20 лет Да с тех пор как я об
этом мечтал и так далее И вот недавно
только еду по Альфа раби ээ смотрю на
все эти Есентай и так далее А когда я
приезжал в Алмату э ужара получается
иногда вот летом приезжал Я всегда вот
мечтал здесь вот тусить просто ходить
видеть эти всякие здания высотки вот так
одеваться ходить и вдруг просто внезапно
пришла осознанка то есть еду по
аль-фараби и пришла со знака О я же я же
это всё видел уже то есть ээ это вот то
что я хотел Я хотел как раз-таки вот
где-то в 27 лет жить вот так и двигаться
вот так делать то что я сейчас делаю э
зарабатывать примерно столько сколько я
Ну хотел и так далее и тому подобное
даже одеваюсь так же как я
визуализировать себе тогда и это было
Вот постоянный фокус я постоянно дал
давал энергию будущему себе и потом в
итоге Короче я даже не осознал как к
этому
пришёл вспомнил что я ребёнком это всё
хотел и мечтал я мысленно его
поблагодарил и он мысленно мне сказал
наконец-то типа Неужели ты типа Оценил
мой труд что-то такое вот и я та и мне
прямо плакать захотелось типа блин Сорри
что я вообще о тебе забыл короче То есть
типа что я вообще на тебя забил что как
будто это вот данность это вот должно
было быть так на самом деле нет ни фига
то есть этот чувак работал то есть этот
маленький
у коре чтобы вот прийти ко всему этому и
уделял время конкретным вещам у тебя не
возник вопрос А что я теперь делаю для
своего будущего вот а а я тогда вспомнил
то что я перестал мечтать то есть в этот
момент я понял то что оказывается я
перестал мечтать Потому что мой
внутренний ребнок он на меня обиделся он
такой подумал метать он даже не
благодарит меня Ну типа зачем и я понял
что мечтаю не я мечтает он то есть это
его прерогатива А я уже дальше исполняю
грубо говоря Вот и в итоге я с ним
обратно подружился и начал заново
мечтать и как только я начал обратно
мечтать обратно визуализировать жизнь
обратно начала меняться то есть и но
быстрее никак раньше то есть мне не надо
уже ждать 5 лет 10 лет это происходит
уже намного быстрее потому что это
даже то что я попал на этот подкаст я по
идее сейчас на данный момент изучаю
частоты людей на другом уровне То есть я
хочу попасть на частоты тех же
миллиардеров долларовых миллионеров и
так далее просто чтобы ощутить чтобы
понять эти частоты
вибрации и как-то всё так произошло что
вот недавно был на
каком-то тренинге
бизнес-тренинг Я вообще по идее это теме
но как-то там оказался среди людей
всяких Да там успешных и так далее
пришёл сюда и сейчас вот это вот всё так
происходит обратно можно я вот добавлю
мысль Просто я был на обучении у
дашкиева и там выступал один парень
блогер Анар его зовут он очень
знаменитый в тиктоке у него на данный
момент 15 млрд просмотров его кто
в его истории следующее он выступал на
сцене и показывал презентацию и он
включил видео которое он снял там 5 лет
назад он снимает комнату и говорит меня
бросили все мои друзья у меня сейчас
минус 7 млн рублей долг это там 40 млн
тенге Да примерно А и он идёт Доширак
стоит Он открывает а в дошираке нет
доширака короче и он разворачивает
снимает себя у него там такой вид очень
печальный и он говорит либо это конец
либо это начало нового и вот вот он
стоит это видео закончилось И он
перелистывает следующий слайд и там
написано 25 млн подписчиков у него 15
млрд просмотров и он говорит всё-таки
это было начало нового И все люди встали
и начали хлопать ему и он тогда очень
классную мысль сказал я эту мысль много
раз слышал но я тогда её понял Я
почувствовал её Он говорит всё есть
энергия вот просто ты Представь себя в
точке б своей идеальной Как ты хочешь в
молитве в медитации кому что угодно
Представь себя там почувствуй эту
энергию какая она вот как Она вибрирует
и начни в своей реальности вибрировать
так же просто искусственно условно да И
вдруг событийный ряд тебя приведёт сам
сюда и ты незаметно Оказываешься
окажешься в том пространстве среди тех
людей которые Ты изначально хотел
попасть на вот эти волны я тогда эту
мысль как-то по-другому понял Вот она
одновременно такая простая и такая
гениальная короче что она иногда
воспринимается как ерунда а иногда как
что-то невероятное и вот в этот раз я её
воспринял как что-то невероятное я с
этой мысли ушёл и начал тестировать и
моя реальность начала сильно меняться я
начал регистрировать события в жизни
которые для меня были нереальны до этого
И вот как ты говоришь там ты хотел в
таком окружении быть Ты оказался потом
раз тут и как будто ты просто вот идёшь
и тебя туда закидывает Это очень
прикольно знаешь вот это всё вот это всё
способы управления своим вниманием Угу
молитва - это способ управления
вниманием визуализация способ управления
вниманием вот это а представить те
вибрации - это тоже способ управления
вниманием потому что внимание - это
такой механизм который позволяет видеть
а то чего нет и позволяет не видеть то
что есть Угу то есть Оно настолько
избирательное ты можешь видеть то чего
ещё нет другие люди не видят потому что
этого нет но ты видишь Угу и ты это
позволяет тебе не видеть то что реально
есть Вот у тебя есть недостатки люди
говорят у тебя есть недостатки а ты не
видишь ты не видишь Или там у тебя
изъяны какие-то в тебе изъяны ты не
видишь потому что для твоей цели Они не
имеют значения Да да да о'кей и это вот
это избирательность внимание - это как
раз то что заставляет тебя поверить в то
что ты другой вы знаете Интересно такую
вещь Я заметил что ну в этой жизни
всегда же есть и хорошая новость и
плохая новость хорошая новость в том
что когда вы
счастливы время летит быстро Угу А когда
вы несчастные время летит медленно Угу А
нам же хочется жить быльше дольше и
получается так что счастье нас
убивает интересная мысль
вот простой Я изучал по поводу
замедления и ускорения времени Я заметил
такую вещь когда кого-то ждёшь время
очень медленно движется когда тебе
стоматолог сверлит зуб это просто
нереально 1 минута как целая вечность
заметили Да этот подкаст идт быстро
Каждый раз когда вы чувствуете боль
Каждый раз когда Вы вынуждены проявлять
терпение потому что вот это нетерпение
тоже замедляет время время замедляется
вроде кажется блин это же классно
замедлять время да а с другой стороны
видите Парадокс жизни заключается в том
что каждый раз когда нам хорошо когда мы
счастливы мы радостны мы в потоке время
исчезает мы оно пролетает вот так да это
вообще интересная тема замедление и
ускорение времени я вот наверное
последний год с этой мыслью живу о том
что когда много работы много людей И эта
энергия потока Я понимаю что я
разгоняюсь что я становлюсь быстрее
и такая мысль пришла что Чем выше
скорость тем меньше времени для манёвра
и чем стремительнее я несусь тем у меня
меньше возможности повернуть Я меньше
вижу я просто несусь куда-то я вот
приезжаю в Астану домой и я намеренно
замедляются но вс станови
качество видео становится H ты видишь
больше деталей ты
замедляться интереснее потом ты
понимаешь о сейчас я разгоняюсь работа
проект разгоняюсь разгоняюсь и опять
замедлять этим временем как вы это
делаете знаеш Я почему в Сеп очень часто
уезжаю в Сеп в аул и так далее там день
совсем другой день длинный длинный
успеваешь искупаться и высохнуть и
книжку почитать и на лошади покататься и
и самое интересное вы знаете интересную
такую веь я подметил Дело в том что
когда мы в потоке когда мы что-то делаем
Мы спешим и так далее время летит очень
быстро и это знаете происходит Почему
Потому что мы чего-то хотим
у один из лучших способов один из лучших
способов ощутить глубокое счастье и жить
спокойной размеренной жизнь вот заметьте
счастье Оно всегда сырце со спокойствием
есть такое Да такое размеренность
спокойствие счастливый человек не
суетливый человек согласны дагу а для
этого нужно перестать хотеть
Угу когда ты смотрите когда ты не хочешь
ничего Ты весь мир принимаешь как есть и
ты радуешься Вот пока об случился ты
радуешься Да да да удача случилась ты
радуешься Зачем тебе гнаться только за
удачей не надо никуда гнаться и в
результате Происходит что ты вот вот
тогда Ты ощущаешь глубокое Счастье
глубокое счастье и при этом у тебя жизнь
не не несётся как лошадь Угу И ты не
спешишь потому что каждый раз когда ты
чего-то хочешь смотрите точка Фокуса
смещается в будущее
Да каждый раз ваше хотение выбивает вас
в будущее вот как Арман всё
Да и ты добиваешься каких-то целе а
потом такой хвост озна что главно цель в
жизни быть счастливым а ты всё время
туда гоняешь и проблема людей в том что
они гоняются за счастьем и у меня есть
такое высказывание для того чтобы стать
успешным нужно бежать А для того чтобы
стать счастливым нужно
остановиться нужно остановиться А чтобы
остановиться нужно перестать хотеть Угу
А как правило что мы хотим мы хотим
только хорошего Угу И мы не хотим
плохого А когда ты перестаешь хотеть
хорошего Ты значит принимаешь Помните я
говорил про принять ты принимаешь и
плохое и хорошее любое событие в жизни
ты принимаешь и ты становишься
счастливым тогда я вот да не говори
говори я вот например к мне помогло Как
относиться перестать делить вот так ярко
плохое и хорошее а день и ночь
Вот мне кажется в природе создано всё
для того чтобы мы с этого считывать
знаки Мне кажется Всевышний это создал
чтобы мы а Наблюдая за этим понимали что
в этом есть большой какой-то смысл я
думаю ну я же не ругаюсь на ночь что она
наступает и люди не ругаются же нуно они
принимают как есть это данность ну есть
день есть ночь Да там А в разных часовых
поясах по-разному происходит не хуже
ночи или наоборот и бессмысленно
торопить когда же ч И ты не сможешь не
спать Ну да ты сможешь там но в целом-то
Понятно В любом случае это время
предназначено для этого а то же самое
Лето и зима и вот когда я начала свои
чувства эмоции сравнивать именно с этим
и думать что ну настолько всё логично
что да должна быть зима мы должны
замереть должны побыть в этом каком-то
своём состоянии прожить его прямо
полноценно не закрывать его не прятать а
прямо прожить почувствовать себя живым
Зато какой кайф а потом э Мне кажется
вот это вот ощущение же счастья оно же
ещё слаще становится ещё ценнее
становится мы Ну всё равно человек
настолько вот мы всё познаём в сравнении
вот даже тело нам даётся бесплатно А мы
его не купили и вот всё равно мы первый
период жизни относимся к нему очень
скажем так невнимательно и только когда
у нас начинается это я просто по своему
примеру скажу как только у меня начались
проблемы с гормонами всё моё тотальное
внимание полностью Переключилась на тело
стала говорить тело я тебя так люблю оня
начала сразу там режим дня спорт питание
всё урегулировать а до этого я даже об
этом не задумывалась и вот мне как бы а
в этом всём А вот именно в природе я
вижу вот эти вот знаки и мне это помогло
относиться са самое интересное знаете
вот с точки зрения успеха молодёжь вот
все гоняются за успехом за какими-то
достижениями А вопрос так что если ты
гоняешь за успехом то у тебя минимальные
шанс его достичь Угу А если ты
преследуешь быть счастливым то у тебя
максимальные шансы достичь
успеха Потому что когда ты преследуешь
быть счастливым ты перестаёшь судиться и
ты отказываешься отказываешься от вот
достигать успеха любыми способами и что
происходит в исламе говорится что в
одном из Хадисов Что Аллах сказал если
мой раб будет преследовать власть Славу
и деньги
то я сделаю так что они будут убегать от
него А если он будет преследовать блага
того мира то я сделаю так что эти три
субстанции будут бегать за ним как
собачки то есть понимаешь ворен баффет
например сказал так я заметил что
счастливые вернее успешные люди очень
часто говорят нет Угу а наиболее
успешные говорят нет почти всему
Угу Вот я по жизни себе у себя тоже
заметил
что моя эффективность раст прямо
пропорционально тому чем больше вещам Я
говорю нет то есть смысл такой не в том
что что ещё сделать что ещё сделать а
нужно говорить что ещё не надо
делать и когда ты
откидывает статую Давида он сказал я всё
что не
Давид Вот и вы когда свою жизнь
формируете надо отсечь всё что не
приносит вам счастье это автоматики вашу
эффективность вы откажетесь от кучи
встреч от кучи тусовок от кучи лишних
движений Просто вы будете выбрасывать
выбрасывать Если вы будете всё время
держать состояние счастья то всё будет
получаться потому что к счастливым людям
другие люди тянутся потому что
Счастливые люди они как бы излучают это
спокойствие
уравновешенность мудрость и так далее
люди тянутся этот Весь мир на самом деле
работает в твою пользу Угу и таким
образом можно сказать что вот везение
происходит везение А что такое везение
везение вот моём понимании - это
стечение благоприятное стечение
временных и пространственных
обстоятельств Это то что ещё в народе
говорят оказался в нужном време в нужно
в нужном месте Когда ты суетишься ты
никогда не можешь оказаться там Угу в
нужное время в нужном мест и не увидишь
этого и не увидишь Ты бежишь потому что
у тебя и цели там надо что-то за Да и
это очень важно находиться вот во время
здесь и сейчас вот здесь вот это такой
очень тонкий момент когда по идее
спешишь ты Ну у тебя же нету времени
даже понять что ты хочешь что хочет твоё
тело что
хоче есть есть вот такой закон извиняюсь
смотрите есть такой закон что когда ты
спешишь Это значит ты
наращивает гоняешь за результативность
есть такой закон Чем выше скорость тем
выше риски Угу Чем выше риски тем больше
проблем закономерно же когда ты на
мотоцикле Едешь 20 км в час одни риски
едешь 120 км ВЧ другие риски ри Чем выше
чем больше рисков тем больше проблем
соответственно ты часть своей энергии и
скорости тратишь потом на решение этих
проблем да
вот к этому хотел привести то что
оказывается
Ну я примерно осознал то что когда ты
спешишь когда ты не смотришь Никуда
просто вот прёшь и ты уязвим на
манипуляции на разного рода манипуляции
в принципе то есть любые манипуляции
человеком манипуляциям там состояниями
там и так далее и тому подобное Ну
условно наш наш например наша работа она
очень связана с людьми да то есть с
эмоциями с реакциями людей с оценками и
так далее
и в один момент когда-то вот когда вот
этот весь бум начался когда вот стало
очень много блогеров очень много всякого
контента очень много информации вокруг и
ты путаешься во всм этом ты исчезаешь
тебя просто нету мы начали обращать
внимание на цифры то есть цифры начали
нами
манипулировать цифры начали властвовать
над нами то есть это даже не люди на
самом деле это просто цифры то есть мы
даже не знаем сколько в этом всём вообще
живых людей настоящих сколько в этом всм
настоящего внимания настоящего в
принципе к тому что ты делаешь Но ты
смотришь на эти цифры смотришь на цифры
других людей и эти цифры начинают тобой
манипулировать они берут твою жизнь и
вертят как хотят И после этого ты просто
максимально себя теряешь Потому что твоя
жизнь это уже цифры каждый твой шаг
каждое твоё действие должно привести к
каким-то большим цифрам но ты даже не
можешь понять А
нахрена то есть изначально же у тебя
было так что типа ты просто должен бы
так сказать делиться проявляться да то
есть я артист Я просто проявляю я делаю
качественный контент я там делают так
чтобы людей удивлять и так далее но
потом это всё нафиг забывается потому
что из-за того что вот эти цифры и так
далее ты ты такой смотришь назад у тебя
что-то там не очень ты зарабатываешь
меньше чем тот ты там не кушаешь то что
кушает он там и так далее и тому
подобное и вот эта вся хрень начинает
манипулировать и здесь короче ты теряешь
свободу когда ты теряешь свободу в
принципе ты теряешь смысл то есть в
конце всё равно будет фрустрация ти это
вот то что я говорил компоненты счастья
нет Свободы нет счастья ещё такой момент
нужно чётко понимать многие
переоценивают значение цели А вот думаю
цель цель цель Дело в том что ты должен
чётко понимать цель должна служить тебе
а не ты цели когда ты Поставил цель и к
ней стремишься ты по сути выбрал
добровольное рабство выбрал манипулятор
который теперь будет управлять тобой
цель будет управлять тобой а в конечном
итоге цель может быть ложной не Том не
той целью А главное это цель это быть
счастливым и вот про замедление то есть
моё главное Осознание было вот в
двадцатом году когда был
карантин когда всё замедлилось когда
всем было не до успеха и так далее когда
все просто остались самими
собой и вот когда вс короче наконец-то
начал обращать на себя внимание
посмотрел в зеркало я там 85 кг уже вешу
надо всё это уже убирать короче То есть
типа я понял что чтобы Убирать надо
нормально питаться и так далее и после
замедления началось вот это вот типа
любить себя обращать внимание на то что
ты хочешь и так далее И вот как раз
после этого вышло Вот эти много нет то
есть типа много От чего начал
отказываться типа вот это мне не надо
вот это не надо и всё настолько спокойно
то есть Я очень благодарен вообще вот
этому двадцатому году и карантину на
самом деле потому что очень много чего
поменялось в жизни много чего осознало
но опять Вот этот весь весь суетливый
мир он возвратился он даже пришёл ещё
больше масштабе Да как бы и в этом всём
ты обратно забываешься и оказывается
действительно нужно иногда вспоминать и
замедляться просто просто отказываться
от всего этого потому что это много чего
тебе просто не нужно И вот хотел бы
здесь добавить я был тоже на обучении
там такая инфа тоже думаю скрин вставим
человек в среднем сейчас в среднем
заходит в телефон вот как вы думаете
Сколько раз в день Ну много я я
последние иследование смотрел 8 часов
или 9 часов проводит Нет ну это проводит
А сколько раз открывает телефон вобще
раз 100 наве 15.000 2.000 более 2.000
раз да в день да 150 раз разблокирует и
открывает телефон Просто так Просто так
Просто так Просто просто так у меня есть
вот эта манера просто зайти в Instagram
просто так Зачем в среднем 10 часов в
телефоне ужас 10 часов в среднем и я
блогер я вот определённую закономерность
заметил я сейчас перестал сидеть в
соцсетях Я только загружаю контент я его
не смотрю потому что я начал наблюдать
такую штуку я смотрю за контентом и моя
энергия куда-то сливается я
останавливаюсь и такой думаю куда она
сливается что происходит А я понимаю что
просто за 5 секунд вот этого
пролистывание тиктока испытываю смерть
счастье любовь свадьбу драку там же вот
так же в ленте и ты понимаешь что Да вот
вот куда это всё слилось просто мои там
ну гормоны не знаю там через разные
стороны можно посмотреть и увидеть что
реально идёт жёсткий слив и теперь я
думаю а вот есть Люди кто сидит просто в
соцсетях Ну большинство таких и
бесцельно Да бесцельно
Ну вот почему результатов в жизни мало
Вот почему счастья мало в жизни потому
что ты я Ну это же своего рода тоже
порнография жизни ты смотришь на жизнь
кого-то и как бы ты проживаешь эту жизнь
через сторисы и так далее да И вот это
всё ты испытываешь и на реальную жизнь
уже нету
энергии не потом она не такая яркая в
Иста вот допустим у меня есть вотже
электронные час их называю наручники Вот
они наручники Да там звонок сообщение я
их сейчас скидываю постоянно и вот
сейчас стараюсь телефон убирать по
возможности и я был на обучении 5 дней
мы были без телефона Я думал что я умру
вот когда мы сдали первый телефон Я мой
мозг начал разыгрывать страшный сценарий
там позвонят компания разрушится офис
горит дома драка начнётся вообще вот
просто жесть Я открываю телефон после 5
дней и прикиньте ничего важного не
произошло мир как жил так и живёт вот
ничего важного не произошло я тогда
зарегистрировал такой момент для себя
что это иллюзия в телефоне что там
какая-то есть такая важность что нужно
его открывать 2.000 раз Угу то есть мы
даже грубо говоря Ну в туалет ходим реже
кушаем реже прикиньте телефон стала эта
штука она стала реально натуре не то что
продолжением он нашей жизнью наша жизнь
сейчас вся там получается да это
прикольно но тут обратно Такие как ты
говоришь нету плохого хорошего сколько
плюсов благодаря телефону Сколько
профессий появилось сколько пользы
Да сознание и внимание позволяет это
использовать как инструмент а не быть
рабом этих инструментов Да вот это вот
тоже американцы проводили исследования А
по поводу кто сколько смотрят телефоны
новости и они замеряли разных категории
людей и они доказали то что люди которые
смотрят
телефон соцсети раз в месяц новости
соцсети раз в месяц у них самые
адекватное восприятие мира Я вообще
новости не читаю я реально некоторые
новости узнаю когда она уже не актуальна
такая же фигня и вообще я причём 2 года
назад это начала практиковать и очень
Всем рекомендую Я просто очень
чувствительны человек Я когда что-то
читаю я в это погружаюсь всё мне плохо я
думаю я вообще ничего для этого мира не
делаю и так далее я думаю ну я же не
могу ничего сделать реально зачем я это
всё читаю я отписалась от всех
негативных блогеров Вот только где-то я
вижу какой-то негатив всё я думаю нет
всё в Моём Мире этого нет и оно
действительно начало срабатывать это
работает я я у себя в Ленте отписался от
всех в ноль Потом на бумаге составил
список моих интересов потом по ним нашл
ресурс и подписался и у меня нету ленте
новостей ни убийств ни пожаров ни
изнасилований ни аварий ничего нету у
меня там только всё что мне интересно
всё вот это тоже интересный такой
лайфхак
и вот кстати когда я езжу на все эти
баги туры и так далее У нас цифровый
детокс мы забираем телефоны полностью и
люди без телефонов ездят первое время у
нас был даже один случай одна женщина не
хотела отдавать телефон её физически мы
отобрали это была такая истерика Она нас
ть матом крыла вы не понимаете что Вы
творите вы не
осознаётся сколько на мне завязано людей
и так далее и так далее а потом когда
Через неделю возвращаем мне телефон она
не берёт она говорит Не надо мне телефон
так я не хочу я его ненавижу Он мне не
нужен Отдайте мне прямо перед посадкой в
самолёт и там ещё до посадки она на
следующий улетала и вот не хотела брать
телефон вот у меня такое же было
состояние на пятый день когда уже
завершался обучение и я думал о телефоне
я не хотел его брать не хотелось
погружаться туда потому что когда ты
реально пропускаешь эту часть Ты
понимаешь что сколько ты да всего ты
засыпаешь по сути открывай телефон твоё
сознание отключается Ну вот я 3 дня была
тоже на ретрите без телефона и у меня
были другие мысли я думаю всё меня все
потеряли всё там без меня мир с ума
сошёл Я открываю и как никогда Бывает же
три пропущенных сообщения и то одно там
не знаю рассылка банка какого-то и два
там вообще незначительны да Тоже самое я
вот так вот стою и думаю Вот она
реальность Ну как бы снизь немного свою
вот эту значимость как тебе кажется что
что-то про интересно мы же можем
сравнить Да время с телефоном и без то
есть мы такие Ну было время без
телефонов и Мы это помним вот касаемо
допустим моих племянников и моих
братишек Нас трое братья в семье и мы
скидываем у нас есть группа на троих и
мы скидываем экранное время кто сколько
сиди Мы в какое-то время в какой-то
момент собрались Я говорю пацаны так
дело не пойдёт Ну либо ты смотришь
контент либо ты делаешь контент либо
вообще ну надо как-то Ну гигиену
соблюдать цифровую и меня поразила мысль
одного Стендап комика Я забыл как его
зовут китайский Стендап комик он говорит
помните Эй американцы типа помните время
когда в самолёте можно было курить
видели эти кадры где они в самолётах
можно было курить они даже рекламу
крутили в самолётах можно было курить он
говорит помните и теперь Представьте
какая это дичь сейчас как это тяжело
представить он говорит А вам не кажется
что то что мы сейчас даём четырёх
пятилетнему ребёнку телефон через 10 лет
мы будем так же как на дичь это смотреть
что это полная дичь Да ребёнку ресурс со
всей информацией в мире Просто вот так
отдать что это дичь полная Ну так и есть
сейчас уже доказывают сейчас же очень
много детей при рождении запоздалым Да
конечно да как это называтся цифровой
аутизм Да называется и начали поголовно
всем ставить диагноз что это аутизм Да
пока они Начали выяснять А что
происходит Ну потому что сразу телефон
дают А ещё сейчас перекос ещё пошёл Вот
это тоже интересно стало а сейчас
настолько все стали осознанные и
настолько хотят во внимании быть у детей
А дети Почему ещё поздно начинают
говорить родитель мама да например она
настолько считывает заранее то чего
возможно е Да не хватило и вот сейчас
начитавшись на вот этой всей литературы
она настолько заранее начинает считывать
что хочет её ребёнок что она сразу ему
это даёт Ну то есть не так как мы
например росли Да но мы немножко
по-другому росли согласитесь это факт Ну
родители работали Там постоянно что-то
сейчас все стараются родители быть
осознанными все стараются больше
внимания и ребёнок не успевает даже
что-то прогу Кать родитель считывает что
он хочет начинает ему это давать это мне
рассказала моя подруга у которой ребёнок
на начал говорить в 3 года и это вот они
выяснили через врачей через психологов и
потом она говорит мы перестали Мы
реально говорит перестали вот так давать
ему постоянно вот всё что он просит всё
там буквально через месяц но он что
интересно начал говорить уже прямо сразу
фразами то есть настолько он всё это
запоминал но у него не было потребности
это просить прикольно Мне кажется это же
на самом деле сейчас просто идёт э ну
так скажем Перестройка в эволюцию по
идее в любом случае то
мы Ну нам сейчас больно то есть типа мы
ломаемся и так далее но чтобы обратно
собраться кажется то есть ну типа Как
человечество грубо говоря потому что э
это неизбежно Всё мы у нас скоро
метавселенные будут типа Apple Vision
есть да И это уже похлеще телефона будет
штука И на самом деле нам просто сейчас
наверное нужно научиться как-то
балансировать Между этим или же наоборот
то есть всё уже уходит в это всё в это
русло мозг я не то что я не готов Да я
понимаю что мой мозг Он не готов даже к
инстаграму по сути потому Это
закономерный итог Смотрите дело в том
что если посмотреть на эволюцию
человечества мы шли и практически всё
время мы старались обеспечить хорошую
еду жильё Ну материальные блага
соответственно у нас весь фокус был
направлен на этом У всего человечества
строительство заводов фабрик полей и так
далее больше хлеба больше там мебели
больше машин больше больше больше больше
в результате мы загнали всю планету
Земля в тупик загнали У нас сейчас всего
продуктов всего-всего хватает и более
того в какой-то момент Мы когда начали
заводы строить потом поняли что помимо
заводов нужны новые технологии чтобы
эффективно теперь производить мы сделали
упор на новые технологии и сейчас новые
технологии обогнали возможности человека
так же как в своё время в прошлом
столетии вооружение обогнала нашу этику
и мораль то есть ядерная бомба уже мы
ещё сами как обезьяна с гранатой мы до
конца не понимаем опасность того что у
нас есть в руках так и технологии
современные метавселенной и так далее
это по сути по сути да искусственный
интеллект - это ядерная бомба в сфере
сознания Мы ещё не готовы его применить
Мы даже не знаем возможности мы понимаем
приоткрыли занавеску понимаем что
искуственный интеллект может нас
заменить полностью по крайней мере
заменить смысл нашей жизни и вот мы
сейчас находимся на этом пороге и а
из-за этого сейчас вот в Америке один
инвестиционный банк проводил
исследование самый большой тренд он
называется мегатренд называется mental
Wellness это ментальное благополучие у
ментальное благополучие - это основная
проблема которая сейчас на нас на всех
надвигается потому что мы теряем все
ориентиры все ценности мы теряем мораль
мы начинаем терять Что такое хорошо что
такое плохо и это оказывает давление Как
на детей так и на взрослых мы уже как
родители не понимаем как детей
воспитывать дети совсем другие они
аргументированно могут спорить Так что
мы переспорить их не
можем потому что появилась куча теорий
куча концепций куча вариантов и Вроде
всё работает и в то же время всё не
работает понимаете и мы действительно
находимся на таком пороге и я считаю что
вот этот тренд well он в конечном итоге
всё рано одному к одной простой истине
Так что всё-таки делает нас счастливыми
Угу конечным итогом вот мы даже сегодня
поговорили возьмём бизнес что бы ты не
делал в конечном итоге Вот ты цели
ставишь достигает достигает А в конечном
итоге для чего мы живём в чём как бы
смысл и что нас делает счастливее
[музыка]
и вот мы таким образом подходим подошли
сделали такой большой-большой Круг
поговорили Мы обо всём пощупай всё
Потрогай и
телефон телефон и так далее к сожалению
у нас и эфир тоже не резинова но у нас
ещё время есть мы можем об этом
поговорить Я хотел бы поговорить о такой
теме вот смотрите а не думали вы как
влияет
[музыка]
степень ваше организованности в вашей
жизни на ваше ощущение счастья
а очень влияет на самом деле когда Ты
запускаешь
вообще всё на самотёк не управляешь
жизнью грубо говоря своей то не ощущаешь
вот этого счастья То есть ты его не
осознаёшь может ты и счастлив Но ты его
не осознаёшь внимание застревает
постоянно где-то что вот нету да вот
этого ощущения оценки не можешь оценить
даже сй стороны когда мы говорим
Смотрите чтоб быть счастливым надо
остановиться и принимать этот мир какой
есть нет ли ощущения что это похоже на
Сёрфинг Ты просто по волнам идёшь и
идёшь соответственно Есть ли смысл
наводить порядок то есть это же всегда
порядок хаос Что такое у порядочная
жизнь ты берёшь хаос и упорядочивает но
во-первых порядок никогда не победит
хаос Угу также как хаос не победит
порядок это такие как Инь и Янь Да так
стоит ли лоч
вступи в воду чтобы пытаться навести
везде поря Мне кажется во всём важен
баланс вот во всём абсолютно везде
всегда я вообще начала понимать что
смысл жизни - это во всём ловить баланс
между работой и личной жизнью между там
я не знаю чтобы не уйти слишком сильно в
ЗОЖ и не стать такой занудой что тебя
начнут все вокруг люди раздражать Потому
что ты такой гипе идеальный у меня был
просто такой период и я прямо отследи
его и потом поняла что мне от самой себя
уже просто чуть-чуть плохо да что я
такая вся какая-то пра
мне каже вот во всм
абсолютно нужно ловить этот баланс и
где-то с сёрфингом тоже Похоже там же Ба
я вообще офигел когда понял что вот вы
же сказали есть разные типы Свободы Да
[музыка]
и одна часть Свободы короче заключается
в дисциплине То есть я с этого был в
шоке потому
чтом казалось дисциплина это рамки
кажд раз и далее но оказывается
дисциплина это есть настоящая Свобода
Потому что ты сам управляешь своим
графиком там днём и так далее при этом
без
фанатизма я иногда Вот специально прям
реально специально деградирую беру
просто где-то неделю когда ничего нету
нам этому надо
вот это естественный механизм он
специально А у нас это только расслабься
и всё я деградирую сразу автоматически
быстро Да ну специально там включаю
netflix короче типа или ещё что-то
какую-то хрень даже не понимаю что там
идёт если честно беру там чипсы
мороженое всё ужасное всё такое жирное и
и классное Короче всё ха я вообще я
поддерживаю это круто ты да вот такой
такая деградация такой хаос даёт тебе
возможность рассмотреть заново Да
возвращаешь в порядок такой Так ну вот
это мне не нужно было и так ты Като
верхнюю пуговицу расстёгивает вот так
на рубашке и двигаешься Типа такого Да
не это как будто ты все пуговицы
расстегнул такой руку не снял загнул
живот такой Вы на самом деле он прав а
потом застёгивается только то что
реально нужно а потом такой Так а какая
вообще погода сейчас ну вот в целом вот
так можно вот так либо ты всегда во все
пуговицы мне вот помогает мне держать
вообще
ориентир вот в дневнике в личном
это тройка я называю это у меня такой
образ что ты на колеснице и у тебя три
лошади три лошади которые тебя ведут
Первое - это физическое твоё здоровье
второе - это ментальное здоровье третье
- духовное здоровье и меня когда вот я
тоже в хаос когда Прихожу я гою так стоп
Я вообще сейчас на чём еду и чем я
кормлю этих лошадей что я делаю там для
физического так Ага э лошадь уже
уставшая уже так для ментального и я
себе распределяю там так для физического
я там занимаюсь плавание Плавание йога
для мента я там допустим учу язык и там
читаю книгу для духовного это медитация
молитва мечеть это вот что-то такое И
когда я понимаю вот эти три лошади я
такой окей Всё Они накормлены они на
скаку но потом всё снова
сбивается это
классно а вот интересный такой момент
Помогают ли психологи
счастью психология однозначно помогает
Но счастью помогает сам человек вот это
я могу точно сказать Я знаю людей
которые по 15 лет могут находиться в
терапии и вот они вот всё равно в этой
жертвенной позиции всё равно у них
кто-то там что-то виноват и там могут
быть первоклассные специалисты и
помогать мне кажется это вот от вот я
помню Очень хорошо я прямо молилась и
попросила Бога и попросила и сказала вот
когда у меня пройдёт тревожность Я
обещаю я вообще жаловаться что я
несчастливая не буду и вот у меня какда
реально прошла моя тревожность как я
поняла её причину как я научилась с этим
работать всё С того самого дня я сказала
всё А реально и вот мне кажется каждому
человеку у меня вот например на курсе
тоже спрашивают девушки вот как как
понять я говорю А что вот для вас тоже
счастье Определите какую-то хотя бы
небольшую вот эту ступень потому что
человек такое существо нам всегда всего
мало же мы же если даже всё получаем нам
чего-то снова не хватает и мы снова
чего-то просим и оттягивая сами себе Вот
этот момент чтобы просто уже быть
счастливым и мне кажется очень важно
просто для себя понять какую-то вот эту
маленькую возможно возможно большую
деталь реально которую ты достигнешь
например наладить там может быть
взаимоотношения или там принять
родителей Да У всех же своё или там
достичь чего-то у меня был друг и он
действительно сдержал своё слово ну как
бы он есть и он прямо говорил моё Я буду
счастливым когда я куплю машину вот
определённую машину Mercedes по-моему Я
так думала ну а для него это была Прямо
большая цель Он действительно её купил и
мы реально это вот как просто
квашина Печкин я Почему такой был И вот
у него произошло то же самое и мы каждый
раз его встречаем и он действительно
счастливы понятное дело там у него
дальше Всё происходит он говорит вот для
меня это была важная такая деталь для
для моего счастья Ну мне кажется что это
очень важный
момент я ну считаю что вот условно У нас
у каждого есть мы как вот персонажи в
игре какое-то такое пространство И
психический мир создаёт разные
конструкции которые для человека
совершенно реальный то есть допустим там
вот моя супруга Несмотря на то что у неё
там много подписчиков и так далее Она
переживает о публичных выступлениях и
вот вчера она впервые выступала там на
500 человек и для неё Это совершенно
реальный такой забор стоит которого
никто не видит кроме неё но она в него
бьётся и не может перепрыгнуть и это
видно ты Наблюдаешь за этим и так
понимаешь что у тебя тоже есть какие-то
свои заборы какие-то мешки которые ты
таскаешь с собой и эти убеждения они
слетают когда тебе помогает Человек со
стороны их увидеть Да и по сути
психология она помогает прокачивать твоё
сознание которое дальше тебя освобождает
и от других вещей это тоже своего рода
мышца Ты когда понял что в принципе в
спорте всё как это сгибание разгибание
то тебе не можно в любом месте это
делать и на турниках и там и психология
помогает вот так скажем помочь вот это
сознание раскачать А дальше ты его
можешь применять уже как хочешь Вот
хорошо сказал В этом плане да психологи
помогают увидеть то что ты сам не можешь
увидеть и они хоть и не делают тебя
счастливым но помогают отбросить кучу
вещей которые делают тебя не счастливым
это как проводник который тебя ведёт это
вот как ты же сказал что тебя сделало
счастливым наконец когда ты понял что ты
очень много оказывается чего достиг это
твой внутренний ребёнок вот мне
психология показала путь к своему
внутреннему ребёнку о котором я не
думала не задумывалась не знала я думала
я просто вот как как живу так и живу и
именно через психологию действительно
исцеляю своё внутреннее дитя Я начала
выходить в счастье Я вот на самом деле
начала понимать что я становлюсь
счастливой Потому что мой внутренний
ребёнок счастлив Он чувствует себя в
безопасности та же сепарация это что
такое в так модно про это сейчас
говорить по факту это когда ты сам для
своего ребёнка становишься
внутреннего самым лучшим родителем на
самом деле нашему внутреннему ребёнку не
наши родители нужны после 18 лет нам
наши родители вот так глобально не нужны
мы цепляемся Почему Потому что боимся
брать ответственность это же так
ответственно нести всё в своей жизни на
себе легче маму папу обвинить что вы мне
просто в детстве там что-то не дали
поругались делали вот я поэтому вот это
испытываю и вот когда я испытала что я
сама для для своего ребёнка становлюсь
не критичным родителем не критикующий
точнее а становлюсь заботливым когда
начинаю принимать не так как раньше
отступлюсь и сходу Да Начинаем Мы же
сами себе по факту самые ярые враги нам
враги Извне не нужны если так смотреть
мы сами себя уничтожить можем вот так
внутри своими мыслями просто я не знаю
до невозможности И когда ты берёшь и
говоришь нет стоп Ну и что ну и что что
так произошло в моей жизни ничего
страшного я всё равно тебя люблю я тебя
принимаю даже если все вокруг против
этого И вот это вот я прямо как мантру
реально Да как молитву я это в течение
дву лет выговаривал до такой степени что
сейчас у меня это происходит на автомате
То есть сейчас а раньше я постоянно себя
могла критиковать и вот как только
ребёнок это видит внутри моя маленькая
Да сели и говорит Да всё я могу ей
доверять своему родителю вот тогда у
меня принятие моих реальных родителей
произошло моих мамы и папы и тогда
произошло Конечно вот этот Квантовый
скачок когда я поняла что ты же
правильно говоришь ребёнок мечтает
ребёнок верит в бога снова появилось Вот
это Доверие глобальное миру прикольно вы
знаете ко мне недавно обратился один
парень
Бизнесмен и он говорит А я счастлив
говорит У меня всё есть у меня всё
классно в жизни бизнес семья всё говорит
классно и мне говорит везёт ужасно везёт
говорит и я говорю Ну и хорошо И что ты
ко мне он купил консультацию у меня и
говорит А вы знаете Поче купил
консультацию теперь мне
страшно мне страшно от того что я
счастлив и мне страшно от того что мне
везёт потому что я чувствую что
надвигается
[музыка]
[__] большая [__] она соразмерно тому
как я счаст есть вам вопрос я ему
ответил но потом подытожу скажу вам
вопрос А что может предотвратить эту
глобальную жопу если тебе реально везёт
и ты
счастлив как остаться
счастливым можно с вот предыдущим как
потому что смотрите мы говорим Как стать
счастливым както счастливым А есть
другая сторона есть люди которые стали
счастливыми становятся несчастными
потому
что да новые заложники Мне кажется это
Ну если вот связать это с Темой
психологии А это ВС равно тоже как бы
человеческая психология Да психика - это
система предохранения потому что ну это
я так думаю потому что мы вот
Представьте как Насколько сложно
осознать то что ты всё можешь на самом
деле Сложность заключается в том что ты
это не можешь принять на самом деле ты
всё можешь то есть ты человек Прикинь и
типа есть вот App есть Джобс есть
Эйнштейн есть разные люди и они все люди
и весь весь на самом деле самый
интересный момент в том что человек
может всё но он не может это осознать и
психика предохраняет Потому что если вот
ээ психологически ты не предохраняется
Если бы не было этого предохранителя
условно то можно спокойно с катушек
слететь А а как только ты начинаешь
видеть разные ракурсы и то что вот где
стоит блок и так далее Вот как раз-таки
это же как блок действует даже в
психологии говорится блоки Да мы снимаем
блоки и так далее вот мы снимаем
предохранители и всё Мы действуем короче
и то же самое в этом в ощущении счастья
которое может превратиться в несчастье и
так далее значит а человек изначально
был
Ээ Ну в этой настройке То есть он
изначально был там изначально у него
есть там дверь которая закрыта дверь
спокойствия условно то
есть или ещё что-то то есть разные
варианты Да того что он должен отпустить
или принять или ещё что-то если человек
условно он счастлив Но боится потерять
счастье если он боится он Априори уже
несчастлив на самом деле то есть мне
кажется у человека Счастливого нету
страха потому что у человека Счастливого
есть любовь если есть любовь нету страха
Вот и если у него есть страх значит у
него самообман то что он счастлив значит
он отталкивается от внешнего то что он
счастлив А если он отталкивается от
внешнего значит он не видит то что у
него внутри
отм скорее
всего человек таким образом потеряет сво
иллюзорное счастье чтобы затем найти
настоящее счастье потому что психика В
итоге да то есть она всё равно так
сделает чтобы
ты лицом к лицу стал со своей
реальностью В итоге Мне кажется здесь
очень классно поможет духовность Вот
именно в таких моментах это когда ты
ставишь для себя не то чтобы наивысшую
ль когда ты понимаешь вообще Вот это
мироздание и вот например психология без
духовности будет работать очень медленно
духовность без психологии а она тоже
классна но не детально то есть там про
внутреннего ребёнка да про внутреннего
ребёнка ничего не говорится А это основа
это ядро любого человека но когда вместе
это конечно бомба и вот почему у него
такой страх ну с точки зрения психологии
Скорее всего в его детстве была ситуация
как обы
когда он был очень счастлив и потом
что-то действительно произошло и Ему
сказали это как у меня был период Я у
меня что-то происходит А я сильно не
радуюсь и мне психолог говорит А что ты
не радуешься Почему ты не радуешься у
тебя такое событие происходит А я говорю
а я боюсь а вдруг А вдруг что-то
произойдёт имы Давай копать Ага конечно
в детстве в возрасте 5 лет У меня там
происходит тосп и мне бабушка говорит
ака моя вот много смеялась
Да и я такая и вот я остаюсь с этой
новостью и живу с ней в течение всей
своей жизни не радуясь до конца на 100%
а своим каким-то Да счастливым моментом
У меня тоже мысль такая была у меня
всегда такой исследовательский подход
меня интересно изучать особенно не
только свою жизнь но и как это у других
работает я был вот на обучении у
дашкиева и мне понравился момент там
было 150 человек и в течение 5 мину 5
дней обсуждались разные вещи и разные
вещи скрывались Да со временем и
интересный момент произошёл а он
рассказывал кейс у него там есть два
студента одних А у одного оборот 100
млрд рубле в год и у него жизнь такая
гармоничная там нет конфликтов он ни с
кем не ругается всё О'кей растёт там 50%
в год в бизнесе у него семья тёплые
отношения а есть другой У него там 10
млрд рублей оборот в год но у него
войнушка перестрелка всё время какая-то
битва с кем-то он дерётся на него
покушение и так далее И вдруг вот этот
человек а он очень у него такое говорит
Доброе сердце что вы понимали там он
один раз шёл на улице увидел собаку
бездомную и захотел её забрать А в
самолёт не пустили и он частный самолёт
снял чтобы её домой привезти Ну такой
человек искренний но почему-то такая
ситуация событийный ряд в его жизни
постоянно повторялся с этой войнушка и
он пришёл на обучение увидел вот этого и
подумал а что если это реально какая-то
Это моя штука которая порождает события
в жизни и ведь Реально если так
понаблюдать У нас у каждого в жизни есть
повторяющиеся события Оказывается это
называется паттерн паттерн - это вот
какое-то было происшествие которое потом
создаёт подобные
ситуации реагируешь по заданное програ
просто актёры меняются в лице людей обно
Я там начал это наблюдать и начал
выписывать свои вот эти штуки и понял
что вот он классный сказал что наш Мы
каждый 3D принтер своей реальности
который печатает свою реальность исходя
из прошлого опыта и определённых
психологических моментов Да конфигурации
У нас у каждого своя конфигурация и она
создаёт свою такую уникальную реальность
Да допустим ты выглядишь вот так у тебя
своё творчество я выгляжу вот так и у
меня другое творчество хотя мы живём в
одном мире вроде но миры у нас реально
разные это из-за определённых убеждений
психологических моментов и по сути вот
там грубо говоря Вот это интересно
наблюдать изучать и когда ты эту штуку
вытаскиваешь вдруг вот допустим там
страх что после хорошего будет плохое у
меня тоже есть такая штука я её вытащил
и всё нормально и дальше Всё хорошо
наблюдением ты начинаешь замечать и
пишешь допустим я на бумаге пишу о
интересно вот я недавно заметил такую
штуку вот я заметки веду наблюдении Я
целый день пишу что я чувствую допустим
я вижу человека и у меня раз такой заряд
вот здесь
у включён И за счёт этого это позволяет
мне легко находить события в прошлом
которые связаны с этой ситуацией и они
бывают иногда не совсем логичны Да И вот
допустим вот эту штуку когда А вот у
меня допустим обнаружил
что экстра ну рост
равно разрыв какой-то То есть если я
расту Всё вокруг должно ломаться
рушиться я вот в таком убеждении жил и
Каждый каждый раз в моей жизни когда я
рос У меня всё ломалось разрушалась я со
всеми ругался дрался сам Вот так вот
ходил боевик вот прям боевик а потом вот
я кстати с дошки общался я говорю вот я
хочу в этой жизни там что-то что-то
прорваться он говорит Опа а что за слово
прорваться А почему вот допустим цветок
он Как растёт он вот так растёт или он
медленно растёт плавно Почему ро не
может быть плавным красивым и
гармоничным я такой А реально Почему А
реально Почему нет и это убеждение
поменял Поменял и реально в жизни так
стало всё комфортно я чувствую рост и
вот то есть я думаю что если этот
человек начнёт наблюдать за своей жизнью
заметит определённые закономерности они
у него наверно скорее всего есть и
вспомнит перво причину этого заряда
грубо говоря его снимет и его жизнь
может реально существенно извиниться Ну
это моё мнение да либо можно поехать
куда-нибудь в джунгли ты ты как думаешь
закономерности это интересно у меня
даже вспомнит мои компании друзей это
одни и те же архетипы вот у меня в
детстве был двор один такой здоровый
второй веча и у меня в каждой компании
патерн вот прям паролям прямо ситком
какой-то Ага касаемо счастья этого
страха Я вот тоже об этом думал
м первое наверное что со мной произошло
Во что я вот мечтал у меня я в 16 лет
мне показали фильм Секрет и я просто гою
что визуализация это что у меня был
такой ватман а один и все там что я хочу
театр вахтангово кино красные дорожки
всё и я к этому себя настраивал что да
это я не было ни дня чтобы я не думал
там о Москве и о том что я хочу
поступить в этот театральный институт
и потом когда я поступил Вот тут я понял
что я как будто на порог обрыва пришёл
потому что было так страшно что то есть
я всё это время хотел и оно случилось и
возник сильный страх а что дальше а что
дальше во-первых А во-вторых что
настолько есть контакт есть связь так А
я что я много и плохого тоже думаю и вот
настолько ответственность почувствую
того что вот ты Направляешь что
случается и у
меня это потом я постфактум понял что
вот у меня
мы жили в общежитии с гнесин сами это
Академия музыкальная у нас был один душ
внизу и я понял что вот у меня отследил
тоже за собой что каждый раз когда я
приходил в душ каждый раз это тоже
как-то Ну вода смывает Я очень люблю
воду я молился это был мой намаз
практически каждый есть там свои тоже Ну
молитва своя и благодарность Я думаю Вот
что не даёт провалиться в эту пост
счастья пост счастья это благодарность Я
благодарил за каждого за всё вот Я
останавливался благодарил за то что это
не случайное совпадение что это я тоже
для этого много что делаю и благодаря за
это я это осязания что Вот я
действительно я не зря вот синдром
самозванца тоже пропадает когда
благодаришь и я думаю наверное страх
после счастья - это синдром самозванца
наверное что ты думаешь А я вообще
достоин такого счастья сейчас сейчас мир
поймёт что я не такой крутой
ИТ
интересно наблюдать конечно за вашими
рассуждениями и вот что я этому человеку
посоветовал А дело в том что у нас у
всех в голове сидит жёсткий паттерн
который подразумевает что всё надо
заслужить да и это Это правильный
паттерн его не надо уничтожать
действительно мы всё должны заслужить И
когда в твоей жизни ты чувствуешь себя
счастливым и тебе ещё везёт то у нас
возникает ощущение блин А за что мне это
за что Я же не заслужил за что ты
правильно подметил синдром самозванца и
вот самый лучший и лёгкий способ не
копая во всей этой психологии в детстве
и так далее этот страх снять это начать
благодарить Всевышнего потому что это
пришло от Всевышнего ты его благодаришь
и тут возникает такой механизм
тривиальный когда ты благодаришь наш
мозг начинает думат так Но я же
отблагодарил А когда ты отблагодарил то
вы в
расчёте когда ты мне что-то делаешь
Когда ты мне что-то делаешь например ты
мне принёс сейчас кофе например да я
тебе говорю спасибо большое всё Мы в
расчёте это механизм жёсткий Его
невозможно изменить поэтому один способ
Можно конечно копаться в своей
психологии а второй механизм гораздо
проще ты начинаешь благодарить
Всевышнего за то что за всё что он
сделал для тея и делает и благодаря
этому у тебя происходит обнуление твоих
обязательств перед кем-то ты не
чувствуешь что ты кому-то должен ты не
чувствуешь что ты кому-то теперь обязан
ты не чувствуешь что теперь за это идёт
Расплата Да потому что произошёл
расчёт и этот ментальный расчёт страшно
работает когда ты начинаешь благодарить
самое интересное ты начинаешь
благодарить из-за того что ты
благодаришь с тобой случается ещё больше
хороших вещей а из-за этого ты
благодаришь ещё больше чтобы снять свои
страхи и с тобой случается ещё больше
хороших вещей и в какой-то момент ты
начинаешь чётко понимать прямую связь
чем Больше благодарности тем больше
хорошо Хорошего с тобой случается Угу то
есть хорошее - это на самом деле есть
ответ на твои на твою благодарность Вот
это очень-очень важно благодарность -
сильнейший инструмент
а быть счастливым и самое главное не
просто быть счастливым а остаться на
уровне счастья то есть не скатиться в
страх не скатиться в беспокойство
переживания и так да И вот тут хотел
добавить что Ну у некоторых слушателей
зрителей может возникнуть Вопрос такой
типа А если вот Не за что вот сейчас
благодарить У меня всё плохо да просто
ну часто вижу такое в дайрект когда вот
такое допустим кому-то отвечаю и вот
люди такое возражение Да отправляют и я
для себя вот когда у меня доходит до
какого-то дна Да такое состояние и я
начинаю благодарить Вот и у меня на
заставке стоит
поэтому я согласен 100% здесь Да вот
добавлю Эйнштейн ещё в своё время сказал
для того чтобы быть счастливым
Достаточно уже того что вы есть да Вот и
я говорю вот я встаю с утра и думаю Блин
так у меня сейчас есть шанс
сфокусироваться На плохом негативе и он
масштабируется либо мне сейчас силой
своего своей воли нужно
сконцентрироваться на всём хорошем и
Прикольно вот позавчера я Выложил сторис
о том что если тебе Ну если ты проснулся
сегодня утром по сути это же реально
крутая возможность и шанс и потом
приложил ещё песню Там скриптонита тебе
дали утро там есть строчка такое Просто
он сказал одним пром тебе дали утро и
прикольно что я его в обед встретил
скриптонита короче в жизни и я говорю я
говорю братан Вот говорю Базару нет эта
фраза он говорит Ну да Дада прикольно и
я реально в этой фразе вот для себя
много раз ловил на мысли что Всё
достаточно и вот недавно у кого-то видел
видео такое Типа если бы тебе дали Там
миллиард долларов и ты умрёшь либо тебе
бы дали следующее утро что бы ты выбрал
и ты реально понимаешь что просто утро
оно дороже миллиарда долларов ну просто
это реально дороже и в этой фразе Мне
кажется всё ну типа тебе дали утро всё
ещё самое интересное такой
момент это для людей которые не видят
ничего хорошего в своей жизни и не
благодарят каждый раз Когда
вы думаете и говорите что вам не за что
благодарить то скоро вы пробьёт дно Да
вы пробьёт д дно и поймёте что насколько
бывает ещё хуже ситуация чем сейчас и
тогда вы начинаете вот эту теперь
ситуацию думать Да я какое было классное
это если вы не благодарите вы ещё ниже
опуститесь и каждый раз будете думать
блин какой я дурак не благодарил Зато
всё равно закончится тем что либо Вы
плохо кончи либо начнёте и здесь есть
Ключевая одна мысль которая очень сильно
помогает вот взять ответственность за
себя за свою жизнь Что весь мир - это
зеркало и ты получаешь то что излучаешь
и все люди вокруг - это ходящие зеркала
и весь мир зеркалит тебя и естественно
если ты грустишь то в зеркале отразится
Это если ты туда улыбнёшься то и это
отразится да естественно но зеркало оно
немножко всегда идёт с небольшим
опозданием отзеркаливает поэтому есть
смысл немножко поверить в то что
стоит того чтобы потерпеть и попробовать
поверить в это и начать с сегодняшнего
дня что-то реально менять И вот эта идея
мира это зеркало очень сильно возвращает
ответственность за жизнь мне ещё очень
понравилось
выражение Сначала ты потом тебе если
начать так жить то становится очень
просто если ты хоче полу
много радости Попробуй подарить эту
Радость в начале окружающим людям одними
словами одно и тоже да вот как-то
сначала ты не надо вот сидеть вот люди
которые ты говоришь а мне нет за что Да
там может благодарить Да я тоже как бы
встречаю такое и надо сначала что-то
самому сделать и то же самое Это же
касается негатива и тоже самое Да это
будет касаться этого у меня как раз вот
в молитве в которой рассказывал она в
какой-то момент эволюционировала потому
что я там части у меня была часть
запроса Я всегда просил есть четыре по
четырём направлениям
Это я просил сил физических Я просил
вдохновения Я просил
э людей и любовь а потом это
эволюционировала с в благодарность когда
я до меня дошло что нужно не просить
вперёд туда а благодарить за тех за
сегодня что у меня есть за сегодняшнюю
физическую силу за сегодняшнее
вдохновение
ня любов и я перестаю программировать
себя как бы на будущее просить от этого
жизнь становится очень интересной очень
потому что когда ты понимаешь Окей я это
прошу я это прошу это приходит то ты
такой ну вот я туда я иду а когда ты
благодаришь за то что есть жизнь
становится неожиданно интересной просто
Приключение Это тот случай который я
говорил не надо хотеть не надо хотеть
когда ты хочешь видишь когда ты хочешь
Ты бежишь ты фокус впереди А когда ты
благодаришь у тебя фокус в настоящем ты
благодаришь за то что у тебя есть
счастливый одно из основных свойств
счастливых людей в том что Счастливые
люди довольствуются тем что у них есть и
они извлекают максимум из того что есть
не из того что будет не из того что было
а из того что есть Они извлекают
максимум из того что есть он кушает
мороженое Он ощущает каждую молекулу
этого мороженого и он здесь в моменте
здесь и сейчас а друзья у нас к
сожалению время подходит к концу
это тема очень интересная очень огромная
и это темы большие глобальные о которых
хочется и хочется говорить и на эту тему
можно смотреть с разных сторон по сути
это мы говорим об одном и том же а
Надеюсь мы принесли пользу нашим
подписчикам Спасибо что вы есть с нами
ещё раз напомним нас уже
миллион
Ура наших гостей Я хочу поблагодарить за
то что они пришли согласились сегодня
участвовать в нашем подкасте высказывали
очень интересные точки зрения
а Благодарю вас всех благодарю всю
операторскую группу Э ребят которые
обеспечили техническое обеспечение Итак
До новых встреч на следующем гемба
подкасте До встречи
[музыка]